Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. You've probably seen it on TV shows about hoarding, people living in homes so full of clutter or mess that walkways are blocked, doors cannot be opened, and full rooms are unusable. In some cases, their homes may even be on the brink of becoming condemned. Despite these shows popularity, hoarding disorder itself is complex and hard to treat. It was only given its own official diagnostic criteria in the Diagnostic Manual, commonly known as the DSM, in 2013. There's still a lot about hoarding disorder that is not well understood, but we do know that it causes a lot of pain and suffering for the people who have hoarding disorder and their loved ones.
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。您可能在关于囤积症的电视节目中见过这样的场景：人们居住的房屋里堆满了杂物或垃圾，以至于通道被堵塞，门无法打开，整个房间都无法使用。在某些情况下，他们的住所甚至濒临被查封的边缘。尽管这些节目很受欢迎，但囤积症本身却非常复杂，且难以治疗。直到2013年，它才在通常被称为DSM的《诊断与统计手册》中获得了正式的诊断标准。关于囤积症，仍有许多不为人知的地方，但我们确实知道，它给囤积症患者及其亲人带来了巨大的痛苦和折磨。
Here to help explain more about hoarding, what treatment options are available, and how people can take the first steps to clearing the clutter is Dr. Julie Pike, a clinical psychologist in private practice who treats people with hoarding disorder. She has appeared on the Discovery TLC show, Hoarding Buried Alive. Welcome, Dr. Pike. Thanks for having me, Caitlin. I appreciate it. I'm really happy to have you here on this show today. I think it's helpful to first start off by defining what hoarding is and what it is not. Can you give us a brief explanation of what constitutes hoarding disorder? Horting disorder is a phenomenon. where people collect so much stuff, so to speak, that they can't use their home or their space for
今天，临床心理学家朱莉·派克博士将为我们详细解读囤积症、可用的治疗方案，以及人们如何迈出清理杂物的第一步。派克博士在私人诊所工作，专门治疗囤积症患者。她曾出演过Discovery TLC频道的节目《囤积：活埋》。欢迎您，派克博士。谢谢你的邀请，凯特琳。我很感激。今天能请您来参加这个节目，我真的很高兴。我想，首先定义什么是囤积症以及什么不是囤积症，会有所帮助。您能简要解释一下什么是囤积症吗？囤积症是一种现象，患者收集了太多的东西，以至于他们无法将房屋或空间用于其预定的用途。
its intended purpose. So, for example, we've all seen, you know, pictures and videos of homes that are so cluttered that can move to cars or garages or storage spaces. And the important distinction is that we look for what we call impairment, meaning that it's causing some kind of problem in the person's life. For example, things can become a safety hazard. More frequently, it's that people, loved ones in the person with hoarding disorders, lives are really upset about the clutter and all of the things and the difficulty in getting rid of things. So whenever we're making a distinction of what is a disorder and what is not, a disorder has to cause a clinical impairment. So meaning it has to be damaging in some aspect of life. Okay, so that's the tipping point between a home that's just messy or overly
例如，我们都见过那些堆满杂物、无法移动车辆、车库或储藏空间的房屋的图片和视频。一个重要的区别在于，我们寻找的是所谓的“功能受损”，这意味着它正在给当事人的生活带来某种问题。例如，物品可能会变成安全隐患。更常见的情况是，囤积症患者的亲人对这些杂物、堆积如山的物品以及清理这些物品的困难感到非常苦恼。因此，每当我们区分什么是障碍、什么不是障碍时，障碍必须引起临床上的功能受损。也就是说，它必须在生活的某个方面造成损害。好的，所以这就是普通杂乱或过度杂乱的家庭与囤积家庭之间的临界点，对吧？
cluttered to being in a hoarding home, right? Exactly right. And really what we say in the APA, DSM, the diagnostic and statistical manual of disorders, is that it has to cause distress, but it's more likely that, in my experience, that hoarding causes impairment. So we say distress or impairment. People who hoard, usually hoard things that don't have a lot of value to most people. They buy in bulk. They acquire so many things that people can't move through their homes. It can cause a fire hazard, a safety hazard. In extreme cases, people will lose their homes or they will lose their children. So it can really become very dire for people. Absolutely. And why do people with hoarding disorder have such a hard time letting things go? As you mentioned, a lot of times it's things that
完全正确。实际上，我们在美国心理学会的《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中所说的是，它必须引起痛苦，但在我的经验中，囤积症更有可能导致功能受损。所以我们说的是痛苦或功能受损。囤积者通常会囤积那些对大多数人来说没有多少价值的东西。他们大量购买，获取的东西多到人们无法在家里走动。这可能会导致火灾隐患和安全隐患。在极端情况下，人们会失去家园或失去孩子。所以这对人们来说确实可能变得非常可怕。绝对是这样。为什么囤积症患者在放弃物品时会感到如此困难？正如您提到的，很多时候这些东西……
to someone without hoarding disorder, to the general population, it's something that doesn't have value. Maybe it's paper, maybe it's, you know, old antiques that just sit in a room and are not on display or something. So what is it about someone's brain and how they appreciate in a process information and when they're looking at something, they attach so much meaning to it where others see it is trash, basically. It's a great question. One of the things that we know is that there is a chromosomal abnormality on chromosome 14, which is typically associated with information processing and decision making.
对于没有囤积症的人，对于普通大众来说，这些东西是没有价值的。也许是纸张，也许是放在房间里却从未展示过的旧古董之类的东西。那么，当一个人看着某样东西时，他们的大脑是如何运作的，他们是如何赋予它如此多的意义，而别人却认为它基本上是垃圾呢？这是一个很好的问题。我们已知的一点是，14号染色体上存在一种染色体异常，这通常与信息处理和决策制定有关。
So that abnormality is suggested to play a part here. And I think it's always important for people, especially loved ones who have someone who hoards in their lives, to hear that, that this is not volitional behavior, this is not someone being lazy, this is, this is a genetic, there's a high genetic component. So 80% of people who have hoarding disorder have a first degree relative. So it's a very, very high heritability index is what we call that. So you are very likely to have a first degree relative if you have hoarding disorder, who also has it. And, you know, then the genetic component, the chromosomal, rather component of chromosome 14 is really intriguing too. It's also very, very highly related to other disorders such as ADHD and occasionally OCD, but more frequently other anxiety or depressive disorders.
因此，这种异常被认为在其中发挥了作用。我认为，对于人们，特别是那些生活中有关心的人患有囤积症的亲属来说，听到这一点非常重要：这并非自愿行为，也不是因为懒惰，这是一种遗传因素，有很高的遗传成分。80%的囤积症患者有一位一级亲属患有此症。所以我们称之为极高的遗传指数。因此，如果您患有囤积症，您很有可能有一位同样患有此症的一级亲属。而且，14号染色体的遗传成分确实也非常引人注目。它还与其他疾病高度相关，例如多动症（ADHD）和偶尔的强迫症（OCD），但更常见的是其他焦虑或抑郁障碍。
So a lot of people that I've treated with hoarding disorder have a very difficult time staying focused. and being linear. So when you talk about, we just mentioned about being comorbid. So hoarding disorder is in addition to something like depression or anxiety. I think it's important for our listeners to understand that someone with a hoarding disorder is probably suffering in some other way. So as a psychologist, how do you treat that? Are you treating both at the same time? Are you focusing on what's leading to the hoarding disorder? Good question. I treat both. For example, in my experience, it is very likely, especially for people with later onset hoarding, to have a trauma history, which is also important to think about. It's also, in my experience, this is just anecdotal,
所以我治疗过的许多囤积症患者在保持专注和思维线性方面都有很大困难。正如我们刚才提到的共病现象，囤积症通常伴随着抑郁或焦虑。我认为让我们的听众了解囤积症患者可能还在遭受其他方面的痛苦是很重要的。那么作为一名心理学家，您是如何治疗的呢？您是同时治疗两者吗？还是专注于导致囤积症的根源？好问题。我两者都治。例如，根据我的经验，特别是对于迟发性囤积症患者，他们很有可能有创伤史，这一点也很重要。此外，根据我的经验（这只是轶事），
that people may have addictions to deal with. So it's really important that we treat this holistically, meaning that we look at all aspects that are getting in the way of someone's hoarding problem. And also I want to talk about, I know you and I spoke earlier about this, like how do you define hoarding as opposed to being a collector? What are the differences? Some people might say, well, I have a lot of stuff, but I collect, you know, antique China, for example. So where does it go from just being a collector to a hoarder? Well, collectors are usually very proud, and they usually very carefully display and curate and they usually want to show you their collections. Whereas people who hoard, it's not that organized.
人们可能还需要应对成瘾问题。因此，我们必须全面地进行治疗，这意味着我们要审视所有阻碍患者解决囤积问题的方面。另外，我还想谈谈——我知道您和我之前讨论过这个问题——您如何定义囤积症与收藏癖的区别？有什么不同？有些人可能会说：“嗯，我有很多东西，但我收藏古董瓷器，例如。”那么，从收藏者到囤积者之间的界限在哪里？嗯，收藏者通常非常自豪，他们通常会非常小心地展示和整理，并且通常想向您展示他们的收藏。而囤积者，则没有那么有条理。
It's not usually beautifully displayed. It's never beautifully displayed. And there's usually a lot of secrecy and shame around hoarding. So people hoard in private. And part of the reason for that is they are frequently given the feedback that their stuff is not valuable. And what people need to understand is their stuff is precious to them. Why do you think there's a lot of shame around hoarding? And, you know, if you watch the programs about hoarding, you can see it, you can feel it.
它通常不会被精美地展示。它从来不会被精美地展示。而且囤积行为通常伴随着大量的隐秘和羞耻感。所以人们在私下里囤积。部分原因是他们经常得到反馈，说他们的东西没有价值。而人们需要理解的是，这些东西对他们来说是珍贵的。您认为为什么囤积症会伴随如此多的羞耻感？而且，如果您观看关于囤积症的节目，您可以看到它，您能感觉到它。
You can feel how so many people on the show there's this sense of shame. Maybe it's because they're being confronted by family members and by people trying to intervene about the disorder that's causing chaos in their lives. But what is it about hoarding disorder that might cause a person to feel a deep sense of shame? I think most of the shame comes from being told frequently that their stuff is not worthwhile. and why can't you just get rid of this and it's not that hard and focus and just try a little harder?
您能感觉到节目中许多人身上那种羞耻感。也许是因为他们正面临家人和试图干预的人的质问，关于这种正在给他们的生活造成混乱的障碍。但囤积症究竟是什么，可能会导致一个人感到深深的羞耻呢？我认为大部分羞耻感来自于经常被告知他们的东西毫无价值，以及“你为什么不能把这些扔掉？这并不难，集中注意力，再努力一点不就行了吗？”
Whereas, you know, the person who hordes, it's not easy for them in any way. Their stuff is precious to them. It feels really good to acquire things. We get essentially a shot of dopamine and other feel-good chemicals every time we get something that we view as precious. And we watch the brains of hoarders light up
然而，对于囤积者来说，这绝非易事。他们的东西对他们来说是珍贵的。获取东西的感觉真的很好。每当我们得到我们认为珍贵的东西时，我们本质上会获得一剂多巴胺和其他让人感觉良好的化学物质。我们观察囤积者的大脑，当他们获取某样东西时，大脑会亮起来，
when we're looking at scans, when they acquire something, it feels great. And then if you look at the opposite, it feels awful to get rid of things that you deem sacred. It feels awful to try to focus and become overwhelmed and have a really hard time getting rid of things. So my perception is that people in the outside world usually shame people who have hoarding disorder. they, you know, sometimes they mean it and more frequently they don't. They're well-intentioned. I've certainly had many cases where loved ones go in the house when the person with hoarding disorder is not there and get rid of their stuff. So it's kind of constantly having to keep their stuff safe from the outside world. And what can that do to someone if someone came into their home and got rid of their possessions?
感觉棒极了。然后，如果您看相反的情况，扔掉您认为神圣的东西会感觉糟糕透顶。试图集中注意力却感到不知所措，在扔掉东西时感到非常困难，这种感觉很糟糕。所以我的看法是，外界的人通常会羞辱囤积症患者。他们有时是故意的，但更多时候不是。他们是出于好意。我当然遇到过很多案例，亲属在囤积症患者不在家时进入屋内，把他们的东西扔掉。所以这就像是不得不时刻保护他们的东西免受外界的侵害。如果有人进入他们的家并扔掉了他们的财产，那会对他们造成什么影响？
I mean, I imagine that's not the best way to go about helping someone who is hoarding to. order? Getting rid of someone's stuff against their will is one of the worst things you can do. We've actually had cases where people commit suicide, and I'm not trying to suggest that that is a common response, but it has happened. And I think it just causes a further breach of trust. It makes the person more dug in because it now creates a fight dynamic. And the reality is that if someone has hoarding disorder, even if you clean out every single thing in their house, they will fill that space again. It's only a matter of time. And they tend to fill every space that they are allowed to, meaning I've seen many people who fill their children's rooms because they're running out
我的意思是，我想那不是帮助囤积症患者的最佳方式，对吧？违背某人的意愿扔掉他们的东西是你能做的最糟糕的事情之一。我们实际上遇到过有人因此自杀的案例，我并不是想暗示这是一种常见的反应，但确实发生过。我认为这只会进一步破坏信任。它会让当事人更加固执，因为它现在制造了一种对抗的动态。事实是，如果一个人患有囤积症，即使你清理掉他们房子里的每一件东西，他们也会再次填满那个空间。这只是时间问题。而且他们倾向于填满他们被允许使用的每一个空间，这意味着我见过许多人因为空间不足而填满了他们孩子的房间。
of space. They will buy new storage units. So the analogy I always make is that getting rid of someone's stuff against their will is like trying to pour out alcohol. if someone is an alcoholic, they are just going to go buy more. Right. You have to be ready to make a change if you want to see change. And you said that the person who is a hoarder doesn't usually see their behavior as a problem. So going along with what we just talked about, but everyone else in their life can easily walk in and say, whoa, we have a problem situation on our hands.
他们会购买新的储物单元。所以我总是打个比方，违背某人的意愿扔掉他们的东西，就像试图倒掉酒精一样。如果某人是酗酒者，他们只会去买更多。对吧。如果您想看到改变，您必须准备好做出改变。您说过，囤积者通常不认为他们的行为是一个问题。所以，结合我们刚才谈到的，他们生活中的其他人可以很容易地走进去说：“哇，我们手头有一个问题情况。”
Why do you think that is? Like, is it just because they assign such sentimental or deep value to the possessions they own? Exactly right. So when we're looking at diagnosis, we're also, as psychologist, asked to make a distinction in terms of the level of insight the person has around the problem. And I would tell you the majority of the people I've worked with, I've probably worked on around 400 cases in various ways. And the majority of the people I see, I would say around 80% have poor insight into the problem, which sounds very judgmental. It's not meant to be it. What that means is that the person does not deem the hoarding a problem.
您认为这是为什么？是因为他们对拥有的财产赋予了太多的情感或深层价值吗？完全正确。所以当我们进行诊断时，作为心理学家，我们也被要求区分当事人对问题的洞察力水平。我可以告诉您，我合作过的大多数人——我可能以各种方式处理过大约400个案例——我所见的大多数人，大约80%的人对这个问题缺乏洞察力，这听起来很主观。但这并不是那个意思。这意味着当事人并不认为囤积是一个问题。
They think the problem is that their loved ones have a problem with it or, you know, government officials have a problem with it. And, you know, part of that is because their stuff is treasured and precious to them. And, you know, I have had people who hoard who say, I feel physical pain looking at an empty space. it seems so wrong to me. Yeah, that's why I did want to touch on too, is like it just seems like when you talk about if you forcibly removed things from a hoarder's home and did not address the underlying issues that the aftermath could be even worse than the original situation. It just seems like a lot of sense people feel a sense of comfort when they have their spaces filled up and that
他们认为问题在于他们的亲人对此有意见，或者政府官员对此有意见。而且，部分原因是他们的东西对他们来说是珍宝，是珍贵的。而且，我遇到过囤积者说：“看着空荡荡的空间，我感到身体上的痛苦。这对我来说太不对劲了。”是的，这就是我想要触及的一点，似乎当您谈到如果强行从囤积者的家中移走物品而不解决潜在问题时，后果可能比最初的情况更糟。人们在空间被填满时似乎感到一种舒适感，而
an empty space might make them feel worried, scared, insecure. Is that, is that on point? That's exactly on point. You know, I think hoarding is so complex, given that there's a genetic component, there's a chromosomal, there's so much environmental pieces going on here. You know, especially if you have a first degree relative, chances are really good that you grew up in a home where there was hoarding. So that's probably also comfortable. We also know that people who have trauma often feel safer surrounded by their stuff. I've also talked to people, where they say, I just feel this emptiness. And when I have my stuff around me, that that void is filled
一个空荡荡的空间可能会让他们感到担忧、害怕、不安全。是这样吗？完全正确。你知道，我认为囤积症非常复杂，考虑到有遗传成分、染色体因素，这里还有很多环境因素在起作用。你知道，特别是如果你有一位一级亲属，你很有可能是在一个有囤积行为的家庭中长大的。所以那可能也让人感到舒适。我们也知道，有创伤的人通常在被自己的东西包围时感到更安全。我也和一些人谈过，他们说：“我只是感到这种空虚。当我周围有我的东西时，那个空洞至少暂时被填补了。”
temporarily at least. Yeah, that's really interesting to think about it from that perspective that it gives someone comfort. And as I mentioned in the intro, that hoarding was only given its own diagnostic criteria in the DSM in 2013, but in the past it was considered a subtype of obsessive compulsive disorder. Has the fact that it's been given its own distinctive criteria benefited people with hoarding disorder? And why do you think it took so long for it to get its own place in the DSM? Well, I think it's taken so long because it's been so poorly understood and it's still not really well understood. You know, most of our research started around 1993, which is very late, but we have hundreds of years of documented instances of hoarding colloquially. And there's a reference
是的，从这个角度去思考它给人带来舒适感，这真的很有趣。正如我在介绍中提到的，囤积症直到2013年才在DSM中获得自己的诊断标准，但在过去，它被认为是强迫症的一个亚型。它被赋予自己独特的标准是否让囤积症患者受益？您认为为什么它花了这么长时间才在DSM中获得自己的位置？嗯，我认为它花了这么长时间，是因为它一直被误解得很深，而且至今仍未被真正很好地理解。你知道，我们的大部分研究始于1993年左右，这非常晚，但我们有数百年的口头记录的囤积实例。在但丁的作品中就有关于囤积者的引用。
in Dante to someone who hordes. So, you know, very long. time ago. And the first task force in America to be set up was in Virginia in 1989. They formed a hoarding task force. So this is not something that has gone unnoticed. I think what has really been beneficial with both the diagnosis and with the television shows is that people can give it a name. That to me, the point of making a diagnosis is not to label or stick. And, you know, someone or pathologize them. The point of making a diagnosis is to inform treatment and increase understanding and empathy. So I think really the benefit of having a discrete diagnosis now is that we know what it is. We can explain it to people. We can perhaps even more importantly
所以，那是很久以前的事了。美国成立的第一个工作组是在1989年的弗吉尼亚州。他们成立了一个囤积症工作组。所以这并不是没有引起注意。我认为，诊断和电视节目带来的真正好处是，人们可以给它起个名字。对我来说，进行诊断的目的不是为了贴标签或给某人定性，也不是为了病理化他们。进行诊断的目的是为了指导治疗，增加理解和同理心。所以我认为现在拥有一个独立的诊断，真正的好处是我们知道它是什么。我们可以向人们解释它。我们甚至可以更重要地
explain it to loved ones. And we can work on treatment methods. And I imagine showing hoarding on TV can be both detrimental and beneficial because, you know, in one hand, you have people in the programs who are being helped and you have people at home who see it. And if they're a hoarder themselves or have someone in their life who's a hoarder, they may feel relieved that they're not alone and that there is help out there. However, the people in the show, you know, they could be subject to, like you said, you know, being, I don't know, you know, stigmatized a little bit or ridiculed or this order could be trivialized because I think it's so common for people make a casual comment when they have a cluttered home to say, oh, I'm such a hoarder.
向亲人解释它。我们可以致力于研究治疗方法。而且我想，在电视上展示囤积症既可能是有害的，也可能是有益的。因为一方面，节目中有正在接受帮助的人，也有在家里观看的人。如果他们自己是囤积者，或者生活中有关心的人是囤积者，他们可能会感到宽慰，因为他们并不孤单，而且外面有帮助。然而，节目中的人，你知道，他们可能会受到，正如您所说，被污名化，或者被嘲笑，或者这种障碍可能被轻视。因为我认为人们在家里杂乱时随口说“哦，我真是个囤积者”太常见了。
Like similar along the lines of OCD where people casually throw that statement around, but in fact, they're likely probably don't have that disorder and that there are people out there who do, and it's very detrimental to their life. So with all this shared, given your experience on the TV programs and with clients and private practice, what are your thoughts? And do you think it's stigmatizes hoarding? Do you think it's helped more people get help out there? I think it's done both, and I think it's a double-edged sword. So the intended purpose of the show that I was on hoarding, Buried Alive on Discovery or TLC, was to look at the phenomenon of hoarding and more importantly to investigate treatment, effective psychological treatment. And I think the shows have brought awareness, which is incredibly important. I still daily get emails for.
就像强迫症（OCD）一样，人们随口乱用这个词，但事实上，他们很可能并没有那种障碍，而外面确实有人患有这种障碍，这对他们的生活是非常有害的。所以，鉴于您在电视节目、客户和私人诊所的经验，您怎么看？您认为这是否污名化了囤积症？您认为它是否帮助更多人获得了帮助？我认为两者都有，而且我认为这是一把双刃剑。我参与的Discovery或TLC频道的《囤积：活埋》节目的初衷，是审视囤积现象，更重要的是调查治疗方法，即有效的心理治疗。我认为这些节目提高了人们的意识，这非常重要。我每天仍然收到寻求
help and email saying thank you for showing us. You know, I didn't know this had a name. My aunt has it. My mom has it. I didn't realize I grew up in a home and that's what it was. And so I think it does help validate people that this is a known entity. We know what it is, you know, 2.5% or 2 to 3% of people suffer from it. So you can imagine how many loved ones that reaches and effects. And I think the flip side of that is some people watch to relate and to learn and other people watch to compare. And I have so many people also come up to me and say, oh, I'm so glad I'm not a hoarder. Like I could never be like that. I, you know, let me tell you about how clean my house is. Yeah. And I understand that as well. I think it is a, it's a difficult thing to understand. I get it. And I think anything that we find
帮助的邮件，还有邮件说“谢谢你们展示给我们看。我不知道这有个名字。我阿姨有这种情况。我妈妈有这种情况。我没意识到我是在那样的家庭中长大的，原来那就是囤积症。”所以我认为它确实有助于向人们证实这是一个已知的实体。我们知道它是什么，你知道，2.5%或2%到3%的人患有此症。所以你可以想象它触及并影响了多少亲人。我认为它的另一面是，有些人观看是为了共鸣和学习，而另一些人观看是为了比较。我也有很多人走过来对我说：“哦，我真高兴我不是个囤积者。我永远不会那样。让我告诉你我的房子有多干净。”是的。我也理解这一点。我认为这是一个很难理解的事情。我明白。而且我认为任何我们发现
difficult to understand or to relate to, we have difficulty reaching empathy or compassion. I do hear a lot of jokes in popular media and social media about hoarders. And I don't love that word itself. I prefer to say people with hoarding disorder or people who hoard. It just, it sounds like a slur to me. And I think it kind of has taken on that flavor. Yeah, it is really important, as you mentioned. to say someone, people who have as opposed to hoarders. You know, I think that's really important is how we describe people, even in the same vein of addiction too, because I've done a podcast about opioid addiction earlier in the summer this year. And I talked about people with addiction
难以理解或难以产生共鸣的事情，我们都难以产生同理心或同情心。我在大众媒体和社交媒体上确实听到了很多关于囤积者的笑话。我不喜欢“囤积者”这个词本身。我更喜欢说“囤积症患者”或“有囤积行为的人”。它对我来说听起来像是一种侮辱。而且我认为它已经带上了那种味道。是的，正如您提到的，说“有……的人”而不是“囤积者”真的很重要。你知道，我认为这真的很重要，关于我们如何描述人们，即使在成瘾方面也是如此，因为我在今年夏天早些时候做过一期关于阿片类药物成瘾的播客。我谈到的是“有成瘾问题的人”
as opposed to addicts. So how we talk about people with a disorder is really important. Absolutely. It's funny. I was just thinking the same thing that labeling someone, an addict or an alcoholic suggests that that's all there is and then, you know, we can just put them in a box. And people are so much more complex than that. And I think if people are struggling with empathy and connection to hoarding or to addiction, because they look baffling from the outside. And I often make a comparison between addiction and hoarding. They don't have the same brain pathways or mechanisms, but I think they are equally baffling to the public. And perhaps to person who has the problem. But I think we all know what it's like to feel ashamed. We all know what it's
而不是“瘾君子”。所以我们如何谈论患有某种障碍的人真的很重要。绝对是这样。有趣的是，我刚才也在想同样的事情，给某人贴上“瘾君子”或“酒鬼”的标签，暗示这就是他们的全部，然后，你知道，我们可以把他们关进盒子里。而人们要复杂得多。我认为如果人们在对囤积症或成瘾症产生同理心和联系方面感到挣扎，是因为从外部看它们令人困惑。我经常在成瘾和囤积之间做比较。它们没有相同的大脑通路或机制，但我认为它们对公众来说同样令人困惑。也许对当事人来说也是如此。但我认为我们都知道感到羞耻是什么感觉。我们都知道
like to feel anxious or sad. And that's really how we connect universally is by looking at shared emotions, which are universal. What are some of those misconceptions about hoarding that you think are out there? The biggest misconception about people who hoard is that they are lazy, which couldn't be less true. People who hoard are often perfectionistic, and that actually becomes part of the problem in treating hoarding is that they want to do everything perfectly. They don't want to make a mistake and get rid of the wrong thing. And so they become so overwhelmed, they're not able to get rid of anything, which is true with most perfectionism. Most perfectionists become so overwhelmed that they start procrastinating, which is a huge component. Another
感到焦虑或悲伤是什么感觉。而这正是我们通过观察共享的情感（这些情感是普遍的）来建立普遍联系的方式。您认为外面关于囤积症的误解有哪些？关于囤积者最大的误解是他们很懒，这完全不是事实。囤积者通常是完美主义者，而这实际上成为了治疗囤积症的问题的一部分，因为他们想把每件事都做得完美。他们不想犯错，不想扔掉错误的东西。因此，他们变得如此不知所措，以至于无法扔掉任何东西，这在大多数完美主义中都是如此。大多数完美主义者变得如此不知所措，以至于他们开始拖延，这是一个巨大的组成部分。另一个
common misconception is that people who hoard are, you know, like shut-ins and very reclusive or unfriendly. And that is not my experience at all. Most people that I have met, the vast majority of people I've met with hoarding disorder are very gregarious. They are generous really to a fault, very kind-hearted, are very, very much family-oriented. And of course, there are exceptions. but by and large, the people I've met are extraordinarily friendly and loving and have big hearts. I think that's really important for people to understand that, again, it's not someone who's reclusive and necessarily people who have hoarding disorder are going out every day, going to work, raising families, you know, being involved in their communities.
常见的误解是囤积者是那种“宅男宅女”，非常孤僻或不友好。这完全不是我的经验。我见过的大多数人，绝大多数患有囤积症的人都非常合群。他们慷慨得近乎过分，心地非常善良，非常以家庭为中心。当然，也有例外。但总的来说，我遇到的人都非常友好、充满爱心，并且心胸宽广。我认为让人们理解这一点非常重要，即它不是那种孤僻的人，而且患有囤积症的人实际上每天都在外出、工作、抚养家庭，你知道，参与他们的社区活动。
And yet they do suffer from a problem that's very serious. But it is important to note that too. that maybe some of the things we see on TV programs can be misleading in that way or might, you know, portray people in a certain light that may not necessarily be the full scope of how, of how they are. Absolutely. Agreed. I think people are just so much more complex than, you know, one disorder or mental health
然而，他们确实遭受着一种非常严重的困扰。但指出这一点也很重要。也许我们在电视节目中看到的一些东西在那种方式上可能会产生误导，或者可能会以某种方式描绘人们，这未必是他们真实情况的全部。绝对同意。我认为人们比单一的障碍或心理健康
problem or physical problem. So what about hoarding across the lifespan? I mean, at what age do people tend to show hoarding tendencies? I know you've talked about that genetic component, but, when do we see that part activated and does it get worse as you get older? It does. You are three times as likely to have hoarding disorder between ages 55 to 94. Very specific, right? I have certainly seen hoarding as early as 11, but it's harder when you're a young person like that to know what you're seeing. is this a kid who is just really fond of these things?
问题或身体问题要复杂得多。那么，跨生命周期的囤积症呢？我的意思是，人们在什么年龄倾向于表现出囤积倾向？我知道您谈到了遗传成分，但是，我们什么时候看到那部分被激活，而且随着年龄增长会变得更糟吗？确实会。在55岁到94岁之间，您患囤积症的可能性是其他年龄段的三倍。非常具体，对吧？我当然见过早在11岁就出现囤积行为的案例，但当你还是个孩子时，很难知道你看到的是什么。这是一个只是非常喜欢这些东西的孩子吗？
And the confounding variable is that they have parents. And parents will make them get rid of things. And in fact, I have had an increasing number of parents contact me and say, you know, I'm worried about my child. Could we come in and talk about their behaviors? Which I love. I love the idea that increased awareness of hoarding, both through the creation of this separate diagnosis in 2013 and increased awareness through the television shows and talking about hoarding
而且混杂变量是他们有父母。父母会让他们扔掉东西。事实上，我接到越来越多的父母联系我，说：“你知道，我担心我的孩子。我们能进来谈谈他们的行为吗？”我喜欢这一点。我喜欢这种想法，即通过2013年创建这个独立的诊断，以及通过电视节目和谈论囤积症来提高对囤积症的认识，
has allowed people to look out for some of the warning signs of, you know, my kid can't get rid of things. They collect things. They have such a hard time sorting and settling. And is there anything that we could do so their life doesn't have to go down this trajectory? I think that's incredibly hopeful. Can you describe the process you use while working with a client who is hoarding disorder? I'm not sure if that varies depending on the age, but, you know, say someone in that range, that 55 to 94 range comes to you or their loved one comes to you and they have hoarding disorder and they want to seek treatment. Can you describe how you approach working with a client like that?
让人们能够留意到一些警告信号，比如“我的孩子不能扔掉东西。他们收集东西。他们整理和安顿下来非常困难。我们能做些什么，让他们的人生不必走上这条轨迹吗？”我认为这非常有希望。您能描述一下您在与患有囤积症的客户工作时使用的过程吗？我不确定这是否因年龄而异，但是，你知道，假设那个年龄段（55到94岁）的人来找您，或者他们的亲人来找您，他们患有囤积症并想寻求治疗。您能描述一下您是如何接触这样的客户的吗？
So how I approach working with a client like that is sort of complex. It depends on who's contacting me. I would tell you that 95% of the time, the people who are contacting me are loved ones. And it is very rare that people contact me because they personally want help with their hoarding disorder. The main reason the people who hoard contact me is they have some kind of really difficult circumstance, like they're about to lose their home, they're about to lose their children. There is something that is so painful that it's pushing. them to seek treatment. So it's far more common that I am approached by by families and friends. In that case, I try to provide them resources and I can give you those at the end of the show.
所以我接触这样的客户的方式有点复杂。这取决于谁在联系我。我可以告诉您，95%的情况下，联系我的人是亲人。人们因为个人想寻求囤积症方面的帮助而联系我，这种情况非常罕见。囤积者联系我的主要原因是他们有一些非常困难的情况，比如他们即将失去家园，即将失去孩子。有什么东西是如此痛苦，以至于在推动
I try to adjust their expectations and describe just how difficult it is for their loved one. I try to do what we call psychoeducation, which is teaching people about hoarding disorder and kind of correcting some of the stereotypes that we've been talking about and some of the misconceptions around hoarding that, you know, this is not the problem of a loved one being willful or just selfish or picking their stuff over loved ones, which is a common misperception. Now, if the person who hordes, who is usually brought by loved ones, is willing to seek treatment, then there's kind of a mix of cognitive behavioral therapies that I use. So the first part would be motivational interviewing, which is, roughly speaking, a technique that is used to try to increase the person's desire to work on the problem and get them to commit on a values driven basis.
他们寻求治疗。所以，我更多是被家人和朋友接触。在这种情况下，我尝试为他们提供资源，我可以在节目结束时给您。我尝试调整他们的期望，并描述这对他们的亲人来说是多么困难。我尝试做我们所谓的“心理教育”，即向人们传授关于囤积症的知识，并纠正一些我们一直在谈论的刻板印象，以及关于囤积症的一些误解，即这并非亲人任性、自私或为了东西而放弃亲人的问题，这是一个常见的误解。现在，如果囤积者（通常是被亲人带来的）愿意寻求治疗，那么我使用的方法就是认知行为疗法的组合。所以第一部分是动机访谈，粗略地说，这是一种用于尝试增加当事人解决问题的愿望，并让他们在价值观驱动的基础上做出承诺的技术。
I also use act therapy, which stands for acceptance and commitment therapy. And it's a way of teaching people concrete tools so they can act in service of their own values. versus acting in service of fear or shame or despair and sadness. And that can be very helpful. We also use something called exposure therapy, which is exposing the person systematically to the upsetting feelings and thoughts that they have about getting rid of things and teaching them what we call distress tolerance little by little. We also use some cognitive reframing.
我还使用ACT疗法，即接纳承诺疗法。这是一种向人们传授具体工具的方法，这样他们就可以为了自己的价值观而行动，而不是为了恐惧、羞耻、绝望和悲伤而行动。这非常有帮助。我们还使用一种叫做暴露疗法的方法，即系统地让当事人接触他们关于扔掉东西的令人不安的感觉和想法，并一点一点地教他们我们所谓的“痛苦耐受力”。我们还使用一些认知重构。
and kind of classic cognitive restructuring, you know, the common thought is, I will die without my things. You can see that that is not really going to be conducive to someone letting go of items. Are there particular treatments you think that are more beneficial than others? I mean, I've heard a lot about CBT being used in treatment of hoarding disorder, but do you, I know you use act, do you use exposure therapy, use CBT? Is there anyone you prefer of the other? Is it just depend on the person? I think it really depends on the individual case. And I have had people with sort of higher levels of insight, if you want to call it that, the very first shoot that I did for hoarding, buried alive, the lovely woman that I was working with had very high insight.
以及经典的认知重构，你知道，常见的想法是“没有我的东西我会死”。你可以看出这对于让某人放弃物品并没有什么帮助。您认为有哪些特定的治疗方法比其他方法更有益吗？我的意思是，我听说过很多关于CBT被用于治疗囤积症，但您，我知道您使用ACT，您使用暴露疗法，您使用CBT吗？您更喜欢哪一种？还是取决于个人？我认为这确实取决于个案。我遇到过一些洞察力水平较高的人，如果可以这样称呼的话。我为《囤积：活埋》拍摄的第一个镜头，我合作的那位可爱的女士就有很高的洞察力。
She was very disturbed by the idea that her children would grow up with this problem. And she was highly motivated to change. So act therapy was a great choice for her. She was very values driven. And it's not to say that other people with hoarding disorder don't have their own values. Of course they do. They love their families very much. They may just have a different level of insight. Motivational interviewing is for me more geared towards helping people increase their insight, if that makes sense. Yeah, absolutely it does. Increase self-insight into one-south. That's what you mean. Exactly right. And I, you know, I would also say that there is no gold standard of treatment for hoarding disorder. It is very complex and it is considered very difficult to treat. That's not to discourage
她对自己的孩子会带着这个问题长大感到非常不安。她非常有动力去改变。所以ACT疗法对她来说是一个很好的选择。她非常有价值观驱动。这并不是说其他囤积症患者没有自己的价值观。当然他们有。他们非常爱他们的家人。他们可能只是有不同水平的洞察力。对我来说，动机访谈更倾向于帮助人们提高他们的洞察力，如果这说得通的话。是的，绝对说得通。提高对自我的洞察力。这就是您的意思。完全正确。而且，你知道，我也想说，目前没有治疗囤积症的“黄金标准”。它非常复杂，而且被认为非常难以治疗。这并不是要打击
people because there's certainly progress to be made. And I have had people contact me years later to say, hey, I just moved cross-country and it was fine. So it's really exciting to hear that kind of thing. And I also think it's important to be realistic that this is a very complex problem that didn't develop overnight. It is genetically loaded. These are behaviors that have been entrenched for a long time. There are often, as we mentioned, other moving parts, meaning the person may suffer from other anxiety problems or ADHD. In terms of medication, there is currently no medication that is considered particularly effective for hoarding disorder. That is not to say that medications can't be helpful, though, because like we've talked about, there are often other problems going on. So if a person
人们，因为肯定有进步的空间。我曾有几年后联系我的人说：“嘿，我刚搬到全国各地，一切都很好。”所以听到那样的事情真的很令人兴奋。而且我也认为现实一点很重要，这是一个非常复杂的问题，不是一夜之间形成的。它有遗传负荷。这些行为已经根深蒂固了很长时间。正如我们提到的，通常还有其他变动的部分，这意味着当事人可能患有其他焦虑问题或多动症。在药物方面，目前没有被认为对囤积症特别有效的药物。但这并不是说药物不能有帮助，因为正如我们谈到的，通常还有其他问题在发生。所以如果一个人
suffers from extreme ADD or ADHD, using a stimulant or a medication for that might be helpful. if someone suffers from depression, which often causes low motivation and difficulty moving, you know, moving around and just attending to daily tasks, then they might benefit from what we call an SSRI, a medication used for depression and anxiety. Okay. So there, as you mentioned it, and I mentioned in the intro and what you talk about, it is very difficult to treat, but we want people to know that it can be treated, it can be managed, that there is help out there? Absolutely, 100%. So if someone's listening today and they're ready to
患有严重的ADD或ADHD，使用兴奋剂或针对该问题的药物可能会有帮助。如果某人患有抑郁症，这通常会导致动力不足和难以移动，你知道，四处走动和处理日常任务，那么他们可能会受益于我们所谓的SSRI，一种用于抑郁和焦虑的药物。好的。所以，正如您提到的，正如我在介绍中提到的，正如您谈到的，它非常难以治疗，但我们希望人们知道它是可以治疗的，是可以管理的，外面有帮助？绝对是，100%。所以如果今天有人在听，并且他们准备好
seek out help for their loved one, perhaps maybe they have high insight and they're ready to look into their own issue, what are the first steps they can take to get help? That is my favorite question, is providing resources because I think once we're educated about something, then we can take steps. If we don't know what it is, if we can't name it, then we don't know how to treat it. And luckily, know what those steps are. So there are a couple really extraordinary resources. For people who are dealing with a loved one, my favorite website is called Children of Hoarders.com. And it has a comprehensive index of therapists across the nation who specialize in treating hoarding disorder. It has professional organizers. It has support groups. So lots of really, really good resources on there. And
为他们的亲人寻求帮助，也许他们有很高的洞察力，准备好审视自己的问题，他们可以采取哪些第一步来获得帮助？这是我最喜欢的问题，因为提供资源是我的最爱，因为我认为一旦我们对某事有了了解，我们就可以采取步骤。如果我们不知道它是什么，如果我们不能给它命名，那么我们就不知道如何治疗它。幸运的是，知道这些步骤是什么。所以有几个非常好的资源。对于正在处理亲人问题的亲属，我最喜欢的网站叫Children of Hoarders.com。它有一个全国范围内专门治疗囤积症的治疗师的综合索引。它有专业整理师。它有支持小组。所以上面有很多非常非常好的资源。而且
In terms of learning more about hoarding disorder, my favorite website is called OCFoundation.org, and that's the International OCD Foundation. They have, since, you know, we know that hoarding used to be subsumed under OCD as a diagnostic category, I'm a member of that organization, and so they have just split out hoarding on its own. And there's a lot of really good, important information about treatment. about what it is, about epidemiology, meaning how often it occurs and in who. And so there's just really great resources out there. That's really wonderful to share. I think that would be very helpful for people to know that there is help out there. And as we wrap this up, I just want to
在了解更多关于囤积症的信息方面，我最喜欢的网站叫OCFoundation.org，那是国际强迫症基金会。他们有，你知道，因为我们知道囤积症过去被归入强迫症作为诊断类别，我是该组织的成员，所以他们刚刚把囤积症单独列了出来。而且有很多关于治疗的非常好的、重要的信息。关于它是什么，关于流行病学，意味着它发生的频率以及在谁身上发生。所以外面确实有非常好的资源。分享这些真是太棒了。我认为让人们知道外面有帮助会非常有帮助。在我们结束之前，我只是想
know from your perspective, like, if I'm taking away from this is that even though this is a difficult disorder to treat, there is hope out there, there is help, there are resources. Absolutely, 100%. I don't think anybody has to live with the despair that hoarding disorder brings. And I think no matter how big the problem, it can always be lessened. Even if we can't erase it completely, it can certainly be bettered. And I think most people would just take even a 10% decrease in the clutter or in the chaos and the fighting that can occur. I think it's also really important to teach people how to treat their loved ones. And so I often work with families. And I encourage family members to get help, whether it's from somebody like me or it's one of these websites, because they are really informative.
从您的角度了解，如果我从中得到的是，即使这是一种难以治疗的障碍，外面也有希望，有帮助，有资源。绝对是，100%。我不认为任何人必须忍受囤积症带来的绝望。而且我认为无论问题有多大，它总是可以减轻的。即使我们不能完全消除它，它肯定是可以改善的。而且我认为大多数人只要杂物减少10%，或者混乱和可能发生的争吵减少10%就会满足。我认为教人们如何对待他们的亲人也非常重要。所以我经常与家庭合作。我鼓励家庭成员寻求帮助，无论是从像我这样的人那里，还是从这些网站之一，因为它们真的很有信息量。
So for the family member, the loved ones themselves, to seek out additional help too. Absolutely. Okay. It's very stressful to watch, especially older parents who, you know, have increased fall risks. Absolutely. You know, I get many, many, many, relatives who are very concerned about their older parents who refuse to get rid of their things and it's unsafe. Or it could be a sanitary hazard. And the older people get, the more likely they are to, their hoarding becomes more intense. That's often because a partner has been lost, whether that is being widowed or divorced. So it's very typical once people lose a partner that their hoarding is kind of unchecked and it gets worse and worse. And it's also likely there are
所以对于家庭成员，亲人自己，也要寻求额外的帮助。绝对是。好的。看着这种情况非常令人压力，特别是老年父母，你知道，他们有更高的跌倒风险。绝对是。你知道，我接到很多很多很多亲属的电话，他们非常担心他们的老年父母，他们拒绝扔掉他们的东西，这很不安全。或者它可能是一个卫生隐患。而且人们越老，他们越有可能……他们的囤积行为变得越强烈。这通常是因为失去了一个伴侣，无论是丧偶还是离婚。所以一旦人们失去伴侣，他们的囤积行为通常处于一种不受控制的状态，变得越来越严重。而且很可能还有
some medical conditions that can increase or exacerbate hoarding, such as dementia. And so as people get older, they may not have had a hoarding problem in the past. Their hoarding might be due to a dementia or a cognitive disorder. So it's really important for families and loved ones to get all the support that they can and some really constructive, educated advice. Thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Pike. I really appreciate you sharing these really valuable resources and your really valuable insight into hoarding disorder. I think that people out there who are interested in this topic want to learn more,
一些可能增加或加剧囤积症的疾病，例如痴呆症。因此，随着人们年龄的增长，他们过去可能并没有囤积问题。他们的囤积行为可能是由于痴呆症或认知障碍引起的。所以，对于家庭成员和亲人来说，获得他们所能得到的所有支持以及一些真正具有建设性、受过教育的建议是非常重要的。非常感谢您今天加入我们，派克博士。我非常感谢您分享这些非常有价值的资源以及您对囤积症的宝贵见解。我想那些对这个话题感兴趣的人会想了解更多，
you've provided a lot of really great information to people and that I think will be beneficial. Thanks, Caitlin. I really appreciate you having me on. If you want to learn more about Dr. Pike and her work, you can visit Julie Pike.com. Before we go, just a reminder, that we want to hear from you, you can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And please give us a rating in iTunes.
您为人们提供了很多非常好的信息，我认为这些信息将会很有益处。谢谢你，凯特琳。非常感谢你邀请我参加。如果您想了解更多关于派克博士及其工作的信息，可以访问 Julie Pike.com。在结束之前，提醒大家，我们希望听到您的声音，您可以将您的评论和想法发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 speaking of psychology，全部连在一起，点 org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。
We'd really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcast. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thank you for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将不胜感激。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您收听播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。感谢您的收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。